there's something I wanted to ask Bruce
Springsteen about that I don't know how
to articulate because I'm not a musician
I think in writing hit songs there's got
to be a certain
trick it's like when paying attention
there are certain tricks you can do to
to to bring the the person into the
painting I think there is that certain
things Bruce does and you do and you
know really good musicians know how to
do there's certain notes they hit it's
tension that feeling you're describing
is tension and release so you take a
song like
um uh we'll do an easy Brew song like
Hungry Heart like he it's a very Bruce
Springsteen chord progression
foreign
chords and it starts on major it's super
happy all sixty thousand people in giant
Stadium
where is it gonna go it's gonna go to
the minor which is the emotional it's
kind of the complete polar opposite of a
major chord
the audience and him and Clarence at the
time were playing
the major second very easy interval
different chord same Melody and
Howard you're probably like where's it
going to go next it's going to go to
another
[Music]
but it doesn't one of you just ended
there like your brain and ear wants it
to go to the a flat sus which is what
this chord is called do you think but
but Charlie do you think Bruce is aware
of what you're saying when he's writing
it
maybe not I've I I just spoke to him the
other day and I actually never talked to
him about
um music we always just talk about New
Jersey because we're both from there but
I think no what's great about the genius
of Bruce Springsteen is that it's all
within it's all feeling and I think
that's uh the most important about
writing a song is I can I can talk about
six ways to Sunday about like the
whatever but it's if it's not if it
doesn't feel like a human made it no
other human is going to relate to it so
you speak to Bruce regularly because how
did you meet Bruce
we in the at the very beginning of 2020
um I'd say April 2020 when we were all
um at home we did a New Jersey pandemic
Relief Fund that the governor had put on
uh um it was all on zoom and uh I played
um uh growing up
[Music]
Asbury Park which where I'm from and
Rumson isn't far from Asbury Park so I I
in I think John Landau had emailed my
manager and said that Bruce was really
touched by that and I I'll never forget
getting a call from the 732 number
that's a New Jersey area code right
Charlie
you know you get full body chills when
you hear Bruce's music I get that when I
hear his voice
foreign